Guten Morgen Tim wieso das denn.
Wegen unserer Desinformationskampagne gegen die AFD.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Noah 267 vom Freitag den 14 Uhr September 2018,
soviel als Hintergrundinformationen für aldi Hörer die diese Sendung natürlich auch in 500 Jahren noch nachholen werden.
1000 Jahren.
Ja bin jetzt versucht Klarheit zu bekommen was damals eigentlich schief gegangen ist und warum das alles so in die Hose gegangen ist und man.
Das war das war eine Woche also.
Da bin ich auch schon richtig gerade gewonnen und ich werde nicht schnell grantig aber mir ist auch schon echt so ein paar mal wirklich der Kragen geplatzt so innerlich auch ist nicht teilweise auch.
Ja ja was hat uns an dieser Woche geärgert ich muss sagen es verbirgt sich auch in dieser Sendung wieder eine kleine gute Nachricht.
Tekken Ganze auf sorgsam versteckt worden wenn sie als erstes findet Pflichten T-Shirt.
Sowas haben wir wo waren wir stehen geblieben in der in der Maßen Saga
Dinger da mal in der letzten Sendung noch um Chemnitz da wo wir ja gesehen haben dass der Hans-Georg Maaßen sich relativ klar gegen den,
der Sprecher der Bundesregierung Seifert und gegen die Position von Frau Merkel gestellt hat und dann öffentlich diese Position in der Bild-Zeitung,
vertreten hat und darauf wurde er dann,
aufgefordert sich zu rechtfertigen und erklären was in den da geritten hat ja mir letzte Woche mit der Forderung geendet er möge doch bitte wenn er sie wenn er wenn die Desinformationskampagne und Ablenkungsmanöver so schlimm sind dass er sie als allererstes der Bild-Zeitung berichten muss statt seinen
Herren da möge er doch bitte liefern ne und das hat er jetzt getan,
allerdings echt auf eine Art und Weise wo du denkst,
da gibt's doch nicht also erstens schreibt er in seinem Bericht ja aber jetzt jetzt eine Position geändert ja was natürlich nicht heißt dass dadurch der Flurschaden den er in der Bild-Zeitung angerichtet hat er jetzt in irgendeiner Form begrenzt würde.
Davon steht bestimmt auch wenig in der Bild-Zeitung.
Genau und entnimmt stattdessen,
ist er noch so frech als er nimmt diese Unterstellung zurück dass es sich dabei um eine um einen Fake Video handeln würde aber er ist sogar noch so frech einen Gegenangriff zu starten und kritisiert hier jetzt,
die die Schnelle Veröffentlichung dieses Videos in den Medien wobei noch niemand die Quell und die Echtheit der Aufnahme hätte einschätzen können offenbar
haben die Medien ihre Aufgabe aber ja getan die haben dieses Video nämlich veröffentlichen können die haben im Gegensatz zu ihm hier ich hatte es letzte Woche erwähnt Stern die Echtheit,
an Anhaltspunkten festmachen können.
Und man hätte annehmen können und müssen dass es sich um eine Fälschung handeln könne.
Nein muss man nicht es war relativ klar dass wir uns in der letzten Sendung schon besprochen oder sagt er das war unseriös,
dieses Video zu veröffentlichen was ich dann nachher als echt rausgestellt hat also eine.
Kannst dir echt nicht vorstellen also man müsste quasi Fazit seines seine Verteidigungslinie lautet weil es.
Hätte passieren können dass irgendjemand anderes Desinformationen verbreitet musste maßen sich beeilen schneller selber welche in die Welt zu setzen.
Muss der natürlich bei dem zuvorkommen dann wurde auch noch im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium angehört und.
Das packt er nicht öffentlich danach hat er die,
Union ihm den Rücken gestärkt Grüne und Linke haben den Rücktritt gefordert die SPD blieb erstmal etwas verhalten und sag ja also was wir bisher gehört haben halt über.
Nicht so aber wer vielleicht fällt Dir ja noch mal was an vielleicht kann er ja noch vielleicht können wenn du noch mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenkst vielleicht fahren wir ja dann nette Worte ein.
Inzwischen fordert die SPD aber auch den Rücktritt Olaf Scholz hat es irgendwie
wie hat er das formuliert ohne seinen Namen zu nennen ja also da müsste man ja wenn das Vertrauen nicht mehr da ist dann müsste man da eben auch personelle Konsequenzen ziehen also
die SPD hat jetzt ganz kurz den Rücktritt gefordert dann aber auch sofort wieder den Rückzug von der Forderung
eingeleitet und und dass das Unfall Manöver.
Hat sich schon seid doch nur vertagt weil es wahrscheinlich viel zu kompliziert ist das.
Ja der ja ja sind ja dann ist noch mal gucken und so ne ja.
Teils und vielleicht ändert sich ja auch das Meinungsbild der Öffentlichkeit bis dahin noch damit wir uns dann auch wieder.
Genauso bist du erstmal noch mal gucken ob das ob das jetzt anhält hier das dass die Medien darüber berichten oder ob wir aus der Nummer irgendwie normal rauskommt.
Sitzbank für umgefallen oder das so weh getan diesmal fallen wir etwas langsamer.
Unglaubliche Wendessen entspinnt sich ein Skandal um diesen Maßen nach dem anderen jetzt ist es die Causa Brandner Brandner wir erinnern uns das ist dieser Trinker mit der Machete.
The Schein Pakete wir wissen immer noch nicht was es wirklich war ne also wir wussten schon mal namens dich erinnert.
Ihr das weil also auf jeden Fall ist es kein abendländisches Hieb oder Stich Instrument das ist ganz eindeutig dem islamischen Kulturkreis zuzuordnen also es ist keine.
Ja das haben die aber auch in Ihrem Logo.
Das ist kein Kruppstahl was der gute Mann da hat.
Das war dieser Tweet ich habe jetzt da gezählt also der Mann war da ja abends bedruckt also ich sag das nicht sage dass der Mann ist ein Trinker und hat diesen Typ betrunken Gesetzen seid das ja nur zu seiner Entschuldigung.
Natalie sind feat mit vier emoji ist und 8 Hashtags abgesetzt warten auf die Antifa oder der die das Zentrum für politische Schönheit,
Apps das sind die Bekloppten kunstvolles die in bornhagen rummehren vielleicht können die mir einen Tipp geben wie ich das Gerät künstlerisch gebrauchen kann Raute AFD.
Na ja das ist ja also viele Hashtags ist ja in manchen Kanälen auch vollkommen normal ne also wenn du so auf Instagram unterwegs bist wenn du da nicht in jedem Posting so eine #die an den Tag legst dann Börse einfach nicht mehr dazu.
Jemanden jemand der sich mit vier emoji vier emojis und acht Hashtags ausdrückt ohne da einen einzigen sinnvollen Satz zu formulieren.
Bis dann ist vor dem Zeitgeist.
Ja genau der weiß auf jeden Fall wieder zu seiner Zielgruppe spricht so das weiß ja nur dass man ja nicht mehr Donald Trump aber egal.
Wie wird das auch machen für unsere Themen gibt es einfach nicht die passende Mode.
Kathrin netzpolitischer emojis die fehlt noch.
Auf jeden Fall dieser Brandner ja also wirklich.
Also der Mann ist auf jeden Fall immer für jeden Spaß zu haben weil der so offensichtlich von nichts mehr Ahnung hat.
Dass er dass er jetzt sogar auch noch fällig,
völlig seine Unkenntnis den Maß wird auch noch mal rein Reis und zwar hat er dem.
ARD Magazin Kontraste hier in der gleichgeschaltete Lügenpresse aus öffentlich-rechtlich finanzierten Gleichschaltung Mitteln hat ihm ein Interview gegeben.
Indem er von einem Gespräch mit Hans Georg Maaßen berichtet,
Ungewitter gefragt ja wo waren Sie sich denn unterhalten sollte ja wir uns über einen über den Haushalt und die Mittel des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz unterhalten und über einige Zahlen aus dem Verfassungsschutzbericht und.
Der war damals aber noch nicht öffentlich also dann wird er
wonach gefragt gesagt sie würde wahnsinnig unterhalten außerdem Verfassungsschutzbericht der sagt ja immer die Mittel und den Haushalt des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz und das ARD-Magazin frag noch mal nach und sagt das habe ich ihn doch jetzt schon dreimal gesagt dass wir über den Haushalt des Verfassungsschutzes gesprochen haben und die Ausrichtung die die die Ausstattung
der Behörde ja die Ausrichtung der Behörde das lieber Herr Brandner.
Ist tatsächlich ein größeres Problemchen denn der Haushalt und die Mittel des Verfassungsschutzes sind geheim.
Wird es mal kurz mal einspielen.
Wenn Du möchtest ich würde mich freuen wenn du das Einmaleins spielen könnte.
Ich hoffe es nur den letzten Tag hoffe ich treff den genau.
Da gehören wir nicht zu ja das Problem ist ein Haushalt und Mittel sind geheim
ebenfalls der Verfassungsschutzbericht vor seiner Veröffentlichung und da sehen wir wieder einmal in der du der vielleicht noch kurz dazu,
im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium wo der Haushalt und die Ausrichtung des Verfassungsschutzes diskutiert werden hat die AFD noch nicht mal einen Vertreter.
Dafür hatte einfach die AFD niemanden in den Bundestag dem man ausreichend mit diesen Informationen vertrauen würde unter den anderen Bundestagsabgeordneten,
und jetzt geht dieses Gitter nicht dahin wo MC achso scheiße ist ein Problem,
und stets deiner dementiert das sowieso ein Visum Donald Trump ja auf Kamera auf Mikrofon dreimal gesagt behandelt die Leute wie ein Idioten.
Und und dementierte hast und wahrscheinlich ne können wir es als nächstes an Korrektur bitten an das ARD-Magazin Kontraste gefallen lassen bei der offensichtlichen Desinformationskampagne machen und währenddessen wird hier.
Ich habe genau das kann sehr schön ich habe mit einem guten Freund telefoniert über der sich auch mit diesem Themen auseinandersetzt und wir quatschen sofort hin und dann meinte ich so und und dann weiter so ne.
Ohne dich so wie du weißt doch gar nicht was ich fragen will doch dann sage ich was denn ja die werden dir nicht absehen fand ich sehr schön.
Das könnte schwierig werden ich meine man würde ja jetzt vielleicht auch mal erwarten wenn die SPD versucht gerade mal wieder so ein bisschen,
ja aber der ist bds an der Stelle halt auch mal wieder das Problem weil sie ja im Prinzip die einzige Partei wäre die jetzt hier noch in irgendeiner Form mal eine Forderung aufstellen könnte,
bei vassi Opposition sagt ist denen egal so aber wenn sie halt innerhalb ihrer eigenen Regierungskoalition Opposition erfahren würden so eine Sanktion na ja das wäre ja nicht haltbar,
das heißen dass du während ich haltbar ja nicht haltbar heißt er müsste halt zurücktreten wenn er das nicht selber macht muss er zurückgetreten werden das darf aber noch nicht mal die Kanzlerin.
Das darf nur der Seehofer.
Mir zwei auf einen Streich zack.
Ja aber dann wenn sie denn Seehofer rausschmeißt dann ist natürlich dicke unionskrise am Start dann ist jetzt Bayern Wahl und.
Dann geht halt wild los und dann sagt halt diese groko auseinander und wollen oder nicht.
Ja ich auch aber die SPD heute nicht und deswegen wird sie halt am Ende wieder klein beigeben und das war's.
Ja also ich bin halt mal gespannt.
Aber ich meine Personalzahlen des Verfassungsschutzes ausgeplaudert an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht sozusagen war da nicht was war da nicht was.
Wir erinnern uns.
Dafür dass sie war dermaßen ist Landesverrat ja da haben wir ja wir erinnern uns.
Ein Abgrund von Landesverrat der sich da auftut denn.
Als netzpolitik.org das Konzept zur Einrichtung einer Referat Gruppe 3C erweiterte fachunterstützung Internet im Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und den Personalplan dazu und die,
die Planung für die technische Unterstützung des Prozess Internet Bearbeitung veröffentlicht hat ja dann,
wurde damit wurde da ein Ermittlungsverfahren wegen Verfassungsschutz wegen verpasst.
Stadtteiche wegen Landesverrat ein.
Länge eines Fahrrads eingeleitet weil sie da nämlich eben.
Personelle Planung und sowas können insofern das sieht jetzt nicht irgendwelche Kinkerlitzchen die der da mit dem Macheten Mann ausgetauscht hatten die Macheten Trinker ausgetauscht hat sondern das ist 1A gesagt,
Landesverrat ja und das an eine relativ eindeutig verfassungsfeindliche Gruppe das ist in keinem also das ist.
Und es nicht nur gut belegt sondern das ist jetzt dreimal hintereinander belegt soll ich ihm das noch mal erklären wenn Sie mir den nicht zu.
Und dann hast du da so einen Bauern sitzen ey diese Seehofer.
Was meinte er zu den Darstellung von Maßen des wer was wo passiert wäre wäre ja unschön aber die Erklärung würde ich mir 3.
Würde dir 3na dir mal die mir leid getan.
Na da.
Ich weiß nicht frag mich halt ob Maßen also da muss die CSU sich jetzt auch mal überlegen weil okay wenn,
mein eine Möglichkeit wäre der Seehofer kickt jetzt einfach den Maßen kommst du Besinnung und das wäre wahrscheinlich noch die eleganteste Lösung für die CSU denn wenn anderenfalls könnte sich dieser.
Maßen Skandal durchaus bei den an ich vermute ja unter einem Teil der CSU Wähler durchaus Anstand also vor allem an unter dem Teil der CSU Wähler die jetzt noch nicht abgewandert sind zur AFD.
Könnte ich mir auch vorstellen dass Seehofers Klammern anmaßen dann auch der Skandal wird der die Bayern Wahl endgültig für die CSU dann besiegelt ja das darf ja auch nicht vergessen.
Ja ich denke das ist eh schon gelaufen und wir werden uns in den nächsten Wochen mit der Situation rumschlagen müssen dass eine Koalition zwischen CSU und AFD zur Regierungsbildung in Bayern möglich wäre also rechnerisch.
Und wir dann sagen müssen wir wollen aber lieber Schwarz-Grün.
Genau und daran wenn Sie also ja das ist.
Das Ländle hat vorgemacht das funktioniert einwandfrei.
Ja das wird dann den Grünen auch nicht unbedingt so schmecken glaube ich aber man tut das ja dann auch für den Staat.
Dann sind die Grünen auch in der groko Situation.
Also ich muss echt sagen das ist ne wenn man dass ich jetzt spätestens seit.
Das spätestens seit ich meine das dass ich politisch keine Sympathien für Hans-Georg Maaßen hege ist glaube ich relativ klar spätestens seit irgendwie den.
Und NSA Untersuchungsausschüssen spätestens seit den Landesverrat Skandalen.
Bitte seid allem was er so eigentlich in den letzten Jahren von sich gegeben hat und wofür steht und ich meine er ist mal eingebracht worden mit dem Ziel naja wir müssen erst nach den NSU Skandalen das Vertrauen in den Verfassungsschutz wiederherstellen.
Ja hat super funktioniert voll gut nichts ist passiert in der Hinsicht stattdessen haben wir nicht nur in Verfassungsschutz der einfach aktiv mit dieser ganzen rechten terroristischen Untergrund Zähne,
operiert anders kann man das glaube ich kaum nennen und darüber hinaus halt jetzt auch noch mit dem politischen Arm dieser Bewegung,
rum säuselt und Rum flirtet und meint es ja nicht ganz geil und hier ist noch mal ein paar Tipps wie euch der Überwachung anziehen könnt und hier ist noch mal ein paar streng geheime Informationen die ich euch alle ich gar nicht geben darf und es ja auch alles nur Missverständnis.
Und übrigens es ist ja nicht so als wäre Hans-Georg Maaßen erst seit kurzem plötzlich eineindeutig rechter.
Der hat was hat 96 in der Einleitung seiner Dissertation geschrieben das Asylrecht ist zu einem Instrument der unkontrollierten Masseneinwanderung geworden das ist 22 Jahre her,
da hat der schon Alf die Position vertreten der hat ja die Skandale um diesen Menschen sind.
So viele an der Zahl Kurnaz Murat Kurnaz all diese Sachen das ist immer Maßen gewesen.
Der damals das Rechtsgutachten geschrieben hat warum die deutsche Bundesregierung den irgendwann tanamo verdorren lassen soll.
Das ist das ist wirklich nicht irgendwie so dass man jetzt sagen könnte ja der hat jetzt mal der Tipps heute Bild gesprochen und ein bisschen Vorsicht angemahnt im Umgang mit mit Videos oder so.
Das ist der liegt dieses ganze der der finanziert nicht nur die die NPD und die AFD und die freien Kameradschaften und wenig alles sondern der tut das mit System und der vertritt solche Position seit über zwei Jahrzehnten.
Und aus einer Rolle heraus der eigentlich gar nicht in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen hat tut er das jetzt auch noch und komm noch davon damit weg.
Kommt noch dazu und geht und knallt noch knallen auf der der Bundesregierung einen von Latz also mit anderen Worten macht wirklich Politik ja.
Und wenn er jetzt nicht geht hat er,
gewonnen und seine Position weiter gefestigt dann kann er im Prinzip beliebig aufspielen und dann haben wir quasi in einem nicht ordentlich kontrollierten
mit extrem viel neuen Geldern auch im letzten Jahr Walter ganze NSU Skandal und II Höhe Gott oh Gott der Verfassungsschutz sehe ich frei lass uns ihm mehr Geld geben.
Ja mit diesem Mittel und Möglichkeiten ausgestattet zahlreiche davon eben,
ihn einfach Zugriffsmöglichkeiten geben die andere Behörden so nicht haben ohne groß Rechtfertigung dafür ablegen zu müssen.
Mit so einer Organisation marschiert eine dieser Organisation marschiert mit einer Person als Galionsfigur durch die Gegend die einfach,
Verfassungs gefährdend agiert.
Da kann der echt das Blut in den Adern gefrieren zum Glück hatten wir diese Woche aber auch noch Neuigkeiten die das Blut zum kochen bringen.
Das gleicht sich dann wieder aus Gott was für ein Desaster.
Wir wir sind halt netzpolitische wechselblüter Test.
Wechselwarm wechselwarme gesamt zuständige,
ja was ist passiert also er hat mir vor ein paar Monaten den Fall dass bevor das Europäische Parlament in seine Sommerpause gegangen ist über das neue Urheberrecht abgestimmt werden sollte und wurde,
gab's da werden mit Julia Räder ja voll normal gesprochen die beschrieben hat wie die vorgeschlagenen Regelungen von Herrn Voß in der Führung.
Keine gute Idee werden dann gab es eine Abstimmung darüber die ist so ausgegangen dass entgegen diesen Vorschlägen.
Entschieden wurde und da waren wir dann alle relativ zuversichtlich dass da hier noch Schlimmeres verhindert werden.
Sommerpause war dann vorbei und dann wurden gleich 456 verschiedene Vorschläge verschiedene Pakete vorgeschlagen.
Julia Reda im Blog sehr schön in unterschiedlichen Farbgebungen noch mal wiedergegeben die schlimmste davon kam dann mit großer Mehrheit.
Und jetzt haben wir den Salat nichts von dem was wir eigentlich erwartet hätten,
dass irgendwas davon durch kommt sowas wie Panoramafreiheit etz irgendeine Einschränkung dieses Ulver rechts fahren ist Wahrheit geworden schlimmer noch,
jetzt
kommt also nicht nur die upload-filter mit rein sondern auch gleich noch im Paket das eu-leistungsschutzrecht und das nicht nur in der bisher in den letzten Jahren immer wieder diskutierten Variante nein jetzt auch noch ausgeweitet auf sport Bildberichterstattung,
ja und das hat ein EU-Parlament uns jetzt eingetreten und man fragt sich eigentlich was erlaube das EU-Parlament weil.
Das erstaunliche ist ja das jetzt hier das nicht nur von konservativen Kräften vorangetrieben wurde sondern das in der Abstimmung zu wissen wenn man sich jetzt mal die deutschen Fraktionen anschaut sogar bei den Grünen und die Hälfte dafür gestimmt haben.
Das fand ich wirklich ausgesprochen überraschend ich weiß nicht genau wie das jetzt sich in Europa verteilt hat ist auch letztlich egal die Mehrheit war deutlich da es haben einen Salat.
Sprich wir sehen uns jetzt mit einer Situation konfrontiert wo demnächst halt Regelungen getroffen werden.
Ist das eigentlich eine noch das ehrlich auf den Richtlinien aus oder was das auf der Verordnungen aus passiert gerade gar nicht.
Es ist eine directive of the European Parliament and of.
Da kann man auch sagen ok dann hängt das immer noch von der Umsetzung in den einzelnen Ländern ab sehr viel besser wird es glaube ich nicht werden dadurch.
Na was bekommen wir alles also wir bekommen das Leistungsschutzrecht deswegen wie nie irgendwo funktioniert hat ja.
Sowas hatten in in Spanien dazu geführt dass Google News sofort eingestellt wurde.
Ja habe ich heute einen sehr schönen sehr schönen Austausch noch mal gelesen Sascha Lobo meinte ich hier meine,
dreistufige Prognose zum neuen Kreuz dämlichen eu-leistungsschutzrecht erstens Google schalte Google News in der EU ab zweitens kurze Stille drittens lautes Geheul der Verlage Flehen um wieder Anschaltung und Staatsgeld,
Sammer Nummer 2 ist optional ja so daraufhin antwortete Thomas Jarzombek von der CDU,
digital Politiker sinngemäß naja mein meine Sorge ist vielmehr dass wenn du dann bei Google News suchst du nur noch irgendwie
Russia Today und deutsche-wirtschafts-nachrichten.de wir kannten noch eine Verschwörung Zeit im Meer der kennt sich damit besser aus als ich das denn da nur noch irgendwelche Fringe Nachrichten kommen,
ja das wäre das diesen Aspekt muss ich sagen der ist noch ein ein weiterer sehr,
sehr entscheidender und wichtiger insofern Katastrophe ja Katastrophe.
Außerdem,
es hätte natürlich noch eine Gelegenheit gegeben ein recht durch Remix in irgendeiner Form da rein zu bringen ja oder eine Panoramafreiheit das nutzerfreundliche irgend eine Form zu gestalten nee haben sie keine keine Lust gehabt und,
dann eben diese Sache mit der Internetplattform die deine haftbar sind für die Urheberrechtsverletzung durch ihre Nutzer was sie jetzt eben auch festgeschrieben haben.
Ja also größeren Schaden jetzt wieder so nett
du musst ja auch irgendwie aufpassen mit deinem Superlativen und so nah und das wird aber einen viel größeren Schaden kannst du dem unter dem dem internet dem Internet
mich nicht zufügen ja als wirklich diesem.
Dass dass das Internet mal wichtig gemacht hat das was den
die Qualität des Internets auch ausmacht in dieser Form eben stark einzuschränken und mit riesigen zu versehen also rechtliche und technische Schranken für den für den freien Austausch von Meinungen und Informationen
zu zementieren und das dann auch noch noch auf eine Weise die eben nachvollziehbar.
Und erfahrungsgemäß dysfunktional Sr
das wirst du in die Hinnerk tickle 11er sogar schon die Wiedergabe von mehr als einzelnen Worten aus Nachrichten Artikel lizenzpflichtig ja können froh sein dass sie nicht auch noch einzelne Worte jetzt sitzen sie aber gemacht haben sie dafür nicht keine mehr über irgendwas berichten das wird übrigens auch irgendwann,
call me crazy David es nicht sein dass irgendwann argumentiert wird naja wenn wir hier Recherchearbeit leisten.
Dann ist dieses Häppchen der Wahrheit eben auch unseres das möchten wir dann auch lizenziert haben ich sehe das ja schon im Umgang mit Journalisten.
Wahrheit Patent oder was.
Nee das ist ein es ist für Journalisten ein Problem,
das ist unabhängig davon es ist virtuell ist dein Problem viel Zeit in eine Story zu investieren,
weil gerade kleinere Häuser oder Plattformen die da ihren ihren Fokus haben.
Jetzt die die jetzt nicht noch ein kleines investigativ Ressort können ja die müssen.
Die Leben in stetiger Angst dass ihre Story von jemand anderem vollständig genommen wird die versuchen.
Nee das in irgendeiner Form sicherzustellen dass dass das am Ende auch von diesem Investment Zeit.
Und so weiter am Ende etwas bei ihrem Haus hängen bleibt und wenn du jetzt wird's für psychisch keine keine Verlage oder Häuser nennen aber sagen wir mal bis eine du bist nicht die größte investigativ.
Journalistische Redaktion im Lande ja du hast eine Webseite die funktioniert irgendwie so die tauchen,
freundlicher name der dahinter steht aber der Name ist eben nicht der der größten Plattform.
Sowas wie Korrektiv.
Yanima Korrektiv oder sowas oder oder ZEIT-Online ich wollte ja keine Namen nennen aber du hast dann trotzdem gemacht so du bist jetzt bis jetzt eine kleine Seite so jetzt willst Du natürlich in der Angst selbst wenn du deine Story jetzt veröffentlicht,
ja wenn dann eine Seite wie lange meine größere Spiegel Online ist auf jeden Fall größer oder Tagesschau im Fernsehen diese Story einfach nur zitiert,
dann kriegen die damit schon mehr,
oder mitunter mehr Traffic und damit auch Einkünfte als du also es dir möglich ist das nächste ist wenn die sagen ja okay dann wollen wir Zeit die Wahrheit lizensieren dann wollen wir es doch jetzt sitzen sehen das wird auch noch kommen.
Weil das denn natürlich ist das ein Problem aber wenn du wenn du sagst na ja der google macht Geld damit indem er unsere indem er unsere Inhalte übernimmt ja dann musst Du konsequent auch sagen als nächstes ne die Konkurrenz auch.
Das habe ich recherchiert und jetzt Druck dir das.
Das wird es würde mich nicht wundern wenn das dann demnächst auch noch kommt wäre genauso dämlich und dysfunktional aber.
So oder so.
Mit der Idee auch noch kommen.
So oder so das ist glaube ich auch dass oder eines der Hauptprobleme hier der,
erleben einfach eine weitere rechtliche Verunsicherung die sich jetzt EU-weit ausweitet und da ist jetzt auch noch eine Richtlinie ist sich daneben auch noch in unterschiedlicher Couleur
in Europa ausweiten wird dann wird es eine Land ein bisschen
breiter zuschlagen und können uns nur gut vorstellen was in Österreich Ungarn und Polen jetzt alles so geplant ist in dieser Hinsicht das könnte sehr sportlich werden also,
das Parlament tut sich ja einfach keinen Gefallen und am selben Tag ja beschließen sie dann mit Zweidrittelmehrheit,
da dieses Ermittlungsverfahren gegen Ungarn einzuleiten.
Am Ende ebogo sein wird weil Polen dann wird oder gegen einlegt genauso wie Ungarn schon Veto eingelegt hat gegen die Ermittlungen gegen Polen aber in so einer Situation sich noch so eingesetzt reinzuholen ist einfach strebt.
Noch am gleichen Tag hast du auch noch von,
von der EU-Kommission den Vorschlag ja wir werden übrigens gerne proaktive Maßnahmen zur Erkennung von terroristischen Inhalten und kürzere lost Löschfrist Fristen und
höhere Strafen ja also mit anderen Worten wir wollen upload-filter gegen Terror Propaganda.
Am gleichen Tag und zu dieser zu dieser EU-Kommission oder
der österreichischen Ratspräsidentschaft und mit dieser Kommission kannst du jetzt da deinen kann das Ding jetzt ausgehandelt werden denn entschieden wurde ja erstmal nur die
Position des Parlamentes und damit das Verhandlungsmandat für Axel Voss.
Bild dein Prinzip mit sich selber unterhalten darf weil,
der Trilog ist ja dann sitze ich ja zusammen aus der Kommission, und nicht oft genug betonen wie dieser ganze Prozess funktioniert also die Gesetzesinitiative kam ja von der Kommission so ist es immer das Parlament musste Stellung nehmen das haben sie jetzt getan
damit geht das in die Verhandlung da verhandeln dann Kommission Parlament und der Europäische Rat der EU.
Der Rat der EU Einführung der nicht anderes ist als die Vertretung der Regierung der EU Mitglieder.
So die sollen jetzt aushandeln wie denn das konkret in Richtlinie gegossen werden soll das heißt in diesem Prozess könnte rein theoretisch noch das ein oder andere fallen wird aber nicht und.
Weil jetzt hier sozusagen war hat leider mit Hardliner verhandeln also man kann davon ausgehen im günstigsten Fall würde ich sagen.
Bleibt dabei.
Nee günstigsten Fall übertreiben Sie es noch mal richtig haue noch mal so ein paar Korken obendrauf die,
irgendein Fass zum Überlaufen bringt was dann im Parlament wiederum dazu führt dass wenn es dort noch mal zur Abstimmung gestellt wird weil das muss ja noch stattfinden es gibt dann eine zweite Lesung im Parlament wo das Verhandlungsergebnis noch mal abgesegnet werden muss,
wenn es dort abgelehnt wird ist das ist die gesamte Initiative dahin das passiert selten bis nie.
Das wird aber es wird nicht passieren weil das zum Nachteil hätte das
auch die positiven Verbesserung für Urheber nicht die erste diese Urheberrechtsreform besteht ja nicht nur aus diesen beiden Artikeln 11 und 13 sondern der sind ja auch viele sinnvolle Dinge drin das der Julia Rehder ja auch immer wieder betont hat das heißt das ganze Ding
zum Kippen zu bringen wird niemand wollen da das heißt dass das Ganze also es sei denn sie sich bin jetzt völlig aber das tun sie ja eh schon.
Möglich wäre dass man im in dieser zweiten Lesung dann noch mal Änderungsanträge rein bringt,
die bräuchten aber daneben größere Mehrheitsverhältnisse und das ist wird auch selten gibt gemacht also die,
das wofür man kämpfen müsste wäre eigentlich noch mal Änderungsanträge bei der zweiten und oder dritten Lesung daneben einzubringen.
Na also sieht nicht gut aus um das mal zusammenzufassen ziemlich wahrscheinlich werden wir diesen,
Quatsch so unrecht überführt bekommen in den nächsten Jahren und das macht keinen Spaß und es ist alles doof,
und wir finden das aber Air Force hat ja gute Laune gehabt.
Perforce hat sich gefreut gibt schöne Bilder wie wie er dahin wie ja wie es halt so ein kleinlichen.
Ja scheiß auf Startups.
So wird konnte im konnte da neben einem Interview nach der Abstimmung noch nicht mal vernünftig Auskunft über den Inhalt des beschlossenen geben wenn sich also hat da irgendwie nicht nicht korrekte Angaben zu der Bedeutung des Gesetzes gemacht.
Und ja.
Hast du natürlich am laufenden Band ne auch tatsächlich eine sehr unschöne und schön sie dann wenige Tage vorher hier diese.
Der Protest dagegen Gewinner diffamiert wurde dafür cialis
Sport und Gastwirte Desinformationskampagne so also das sind alles jedesmal wenn ich von ihrem Team an Bord oder Desinformationskampagne hören er das erinnert mich so an wie das langsam,
Alissa ist erinnert mich immer so an die USA Anne und an eben erzählt alles.
Lucy Tea Party sierung und vertrampen unserer Politik Kultur ich meine das für Daniels nicht komplett ungeschoren davonkommen war glaube ich klar.
Immerhin haben wir in ausreichen schlechtes Beispiel was wenn wir mal noch mal so ein bisschen Glück haben auf diesem Planeten in zwei Monaten als in die Fresse kriegt.
Dann weiß ich nicht wie populär das dann noch sein wird aber wir haben ja genug große weitere broken auf uns zurollen die Situation weiter erschweren werden siehe brexit.
Das wird kein.
Brexit ist ein gutes Stichwort wir erinnern uns an.
Die nunmehr vor 4 Jahren eingereichte das angestrengte Verfahren vor dem.
Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte in Straßburg wo,
big brother watch the open rights group und die schriftstellervereinigung Pen zusammen mit Constanze Kurz,
sich gegen die NSA Programme Prism und Tempora gewendet haben.
Nachzuhören auch in Logbuch Netzpolitik 235 nobody is leaking Black Widow wo Constanze zu Gast war.
Findet ihr in den schon und da wäre das da es richtet sich ausführlich von diesem von diesen Vorgängen und.
Spezifische berichtete man sich da natürlich auf Artikel 8 der Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention Konvention die den Schutz der Privatheit für alle Europäer zum Menschenrecht erhebt.
Da wurde jetzt geurteilt durch den Europäischen Gerichtshof am 13. September und da wurde gesagt diese massenüberwachung die das Ciesielski wieder an.
Sie hat keine ausreichende Kontrolle ihres Tuns.
Also lack of oversight auf die Empire selection
francais Studies unterrichtet unkontrolliert und es gibt keine angemessen robusten Methoden da einen Missbrauch zu verhindern also is not sufficiently robas to provide adequate
guarantees against abuse,
das ist ungerichtet und kontrolliert und in keiner Form gegen Missbrauch geschützt.
Und war damit rechtswidrig tja.
Keiner der Berichte kann er der Berichte nicht dazu finde zeigt irgendwelche Konsequenzen und da dazu ja man muss dazu sagen der Vollständigkeit halber.
Hat auch das Gericht hat auch beurteilt dass es keine Verletzung wäre,
Bilder von Artikeln 8 oder 10 der Konvention dass diese die dadurch gewonnene intelligence mit anderen Regierungen geteilt wurde,
hat sich tatsächlich richtig übel finde ja also it further founded the regime for sharing intelligence with foreign government did not while at the articulated Artikel than also das tauschen
der geheim der der so erlangten Informationen mit anderen Regierungen spezifisch five guys.
Ist also hier nicht zu beanstanden durch das Gericht.
Und dann gab es noch weitere Artikel die auf die sich bezogen wurde nämlich Artikel 63 Reitpferd freie und Artikel 14 prediction of,
discrimination diam sie zurückgewiesen.
Man muss dazu sagen dass die gesetzliche Regelung gilt hier im Fokus stand sogar nicht mehr existiert weil die mittlerweile
okay auch schon wieder überarbeitet wurde dieser investigatory powers Act hatte principales schon alles schon wieder noch mal weiter ausgeweitet also man kann ich davon ausgehen dass irgendetwas was hier moniert wurde so nicht mehr vorhanden ist sondern nur noch quasi
im Turbo-Modus unterwegs ist und naja,
du sagtest es schon wir wissen auch überhaupt nicht inwiefern UK zum,
Europäischen Gerichtshof so stehen wird im nächsten Jahr ob sie ob sie das überhaupt noch interessiert was die dazu erzählen haben meinte bis ja aber sie werden trotzdem,
weitgehend ignorieren.
Toom.
Bethanien Aussagen sehr harter brexit kommt uns auch immer noch nicht voran wie lange ist es her dass wir darüber gesprochen hatten.
Wenn brexit wahrscheinlich mehr einige Folgen.
Man hat sie mir das auch noch was sagen ist aber auch furchtbar deprimierend was da gerade ab.
Ja möchtest du noch ein bisschen über den brexit sprechen können.
Ja das Problem mit dem brexit ist ja.
Immer noch nichts klar ist man kann sich das eigentlich überhaupt nicht so richtig vorstellen weil das lustig war vor paar Wochen war ich in der britischen Botschaft.
Garbsen Veranstaltungen Informationsveranstaltung.
Brexit oder dieser nichts Irrenhaus weiß man nicht.
Das war so im Wesentlichen der Informationsgehalt dieser Veranstaltung.
Also hat sie natürlich auf in Deutschland lebende Briten also an in Deutschland oder in der EU lebende Briten Gewand die waren dann auch ganz zahlreich vertreten aber was ich so 150 Läuse oder so.
Und das will aber auch gar nicht von der Botschaft offiziell einberufen sonst klappt dann deine entsprechende.
Diesmal wird Susanne Interessen Gruppierungen von Briten in der EU.
Die sich gebildet hat und die ganz klar gegen den brexit eingestellt ist aus vielen guten Gründen wie ich finde.
Ja aber nichtsdestotrotz den Briten die da mit dem ganzen Prozess nicht so vertraut sind weil die Gelegenheit bieten wollte wissen informiert zu werden,
das finden schon etwas deprimierend an weil der Wirtschaftsvertreter halt am Anfang versucht hat so ein bisschen Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen mit ja ich erzähle euch jetzt mal was jetzt schon alles klar ist.
Aber das war wirklich so ein Häufchen an Information,
oder auch das war nicht alles definitiv ja wir verhandeln ja darüber und das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so sein und das wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht sein dann kann er irgendwie die Nachfrage naja aber
ist es nicht so dass all das was du jetzt hier gerade erzählt hast sowieso noch nicht klar ist weil es entweder mit dem kompletten dir so stattfinden wird oder eben auch nicht und er ja so ist das leider.
Also nicht genau wusste man dich dann bestand die ganze Veranstaltung zu 80% aus nachfragen.
Die ersten nachfragen bezogen sich so ein bisschen auf das was vorher noch so erzählt wurde.
Oh dann taucht dann dann dann kippte diese ganze Veranstaltung um in ein Was muss ich alles bedenken wenn ich Deutscher werden will wer hat da,
Erfahrung dazu welche Unterlagen muss ich da einreichen wie lange dauert das und darf ich noch wieder zurück in UK wenn ich es deutscher werde,
das war der Inhalt dieser Veranstaltung nacheinander einiger Zeit.
Wichtige Fragen zum brexit.
Ja
Panik also die Leute wollen irgendwie nur noch weg oder sagen wir mal so es gab viele die so sagen die das schon durch haben und ich mal so ja und wenn ihr,
was hat der da eine ja genau don't bipur das wäre sein Tipp,
um um um Deutscher zu werden weil du musst ja dann um die auch Einnahmen nachweisen etc,
das ist das das hatten wir schon was was was apokalyptisches dem Moment.
Didi altwirt ich so Hardcore ich will eigentlich bitte bleiben und warum soll ich jetzt Deutschland werden und so die kann dann auch schon ganz schön ins Wanken oder der neigen einzige Sorge war das eben noch so habe ich dann irgendwelche Einschränkungen,
wenn ich wieder zurück will und ja natürlich war das auch so oder so dieses mit also wenn ich jetzt also ich jetzt als theoretischer,
praktische Brite
deutscher werde Wasser mit meinen Kindern was mit meinem Verwandten wie verhält sich das alles noch zueinander was ist mit meinem Eigentum was ist mit meinen Besitztümern hier und da was mit Mifare sie alle sind es ist so ein shit lotan,
Komplexität der sich jetzt hier zeigt und wir waren ja beide jetzt noch mal an,
England auf diesem WMF Camp ich habe da auch die Gelegenheit genutzt mit vielen zu reden und diese Verwirrung herrscht einfach bevor das einfach dieses diese große Ungewissheit dass keiner weiß was überhaupt kommt lernt einfach alles.
Gibt die Regierung die britische Regierung hat jetzt,
sich entschieden wir machen einen Leitfaden für einen harten brexit den sie veröffentlichen werden also mit so was man überhaupt man sich vorbereiten sollte harter brexit bedeutet bedeutet keine Einigung also das im Prinzip.
Nimm mal bitte das als Note deals in a.
Genau das Notiz denarium es gibt keinen also warum sollte man auch mit den noch an die machen geht unter anderem,
können Sie damit rechnen dass wenn sie keinen Deal haben britische Führerscheine nicht mehr gültig sein könnten auf dem Kontinent das heißt sie müssten dann nach Schuhen oder sich einen internationalen Führerschein besorgen
was ich ohnehin nicht schlecht fände weil die fahren auch auf der falschen Seite das ist gar nicht so verkehrt wenn man die noch mal wenn man sich dann noch mal vergewissert dass die,
mit den internationalen Gepflogenheiten vertraut sind.
Die müssten sie könnten gleichzeitig können aber EU-Bürger weiterhin mit Ihrer EU-Fahrerlaubnis auf der Insel fahren,
dann natürlich die aus den ganzen Roaming sind zur aus ne wenn sie dann ihre Insel noch mal verlassen kriegen sie direkt den die Ländergruppe 3.
Ja aber wir haben immerhin noch wärmer immer noch Europa wir fahren ja dann eh woanders hin.
Also das war ja der der Fall der Grundform ist noch mal zum zum Amp Camp gefahren sind.
Ja also dein dein dein Humor in allen Ehren die Situation hat sich noch viel viel also diese ganzen Oh also die die die Debatte
wenn so ist aber erst noch diese und noch Debatten geführt werden weil die meisten Leute sind einfach gelähmt weil in der ganzen politischen Auseinandersetzung gibt derzeit in Britannien überhaupt nichts zusammen zum wesentlichen
besteht die Politik in England gerade da drin,
die Torres bekämpfen sich gegenseitig sind in mindestens drei Lager aufgespalten labour traut sich nicht den ersten Schritt zu machen um zu sagen das mit dem brexit aber eine scheiß Idee weil sie Angst haben sie werden dann als Verräter quasi am Wahlabend bestraft und die kleineren Parteien haben eh keine Chance wegen
Mehrheitswahlrecht in
Großbritannien das ist sozusagen die politische Ausgangssituation und die Unfähigkeit der britischen Regierung irgendeinen Vorschlag zu machen der bei der EU irgendwie großen Anklang findet hat er dazu geführtes denn jetzt
eigentlich.
Von Theorie als gebieterisch gibt's ja 44 Möglichkeiten es gibt diesen Osiris kommt sogar keine Einigung das ist eine Vollkatastrophe kann ich gleich noch mal ein paar andere Beispiele ausfüllen Wasser zur Folge hätte dann gibt's die Option hard brexit.
Da besteigen mal hier voll aus aber wir haben noch irgendeine definiertes Verhältnis zu euch dass es noch nicht mal in Großbritannien irgendwie saattiefe Satisfaktion möglich
also das wären wir sind nicht mehr im single market und so weiter wir sind quasi einfach nur so eine so eine Insel wie Madagaskar,
und wollen mit euch nichts mehr zu tun haben und dass dieser große Traum von trade Deals mit der ganzen Welt der einfach unerfüllbar ist der ist aber selbst in den konservativen Kreisen,
überhaupt nicht durchsetzbar auch House of Lords and II II Kammern hat sich dagegen gestellt also da gibt's keine Mehrheit im Parlament das Paletten muss ja entscheiden dass es mittlerweile schon
dann gibt's diesen soft brexit in die harten brexit Leute sind sich die ganze Zeit bekämpfen weil sie in das halt nicht hart genug ist soft brexit heißt aber im Prinzip sich weitgehend den EU Bedingungen zu beugen,
im Kern wenn sie halt an single market teilnehmen wollen und auch an dann müssen sie an allem teilnehmen das ist ja dann dieses Norwegen Modell auf dass es vielleicht eher noch am ehesten hinauslaufen wird oder das einzige was an ich die EU akzeptieren kann,
Satir Motor na ja wir tun jetzt mal so als wärt ihr noch Mitglied in der EU ja,
spielt mal alles mit unsere Regeln sind eure Regeln die aber nimmt das einfach alles aber und der gibt uns auch Geld aber dürft hat nicht mehr mit der entscheiden.
Da war ich natürlich auch alle Fragen ja wozu haben wir das jetzt noch mal kurz gemacht damit wir dasselbe haben im Grünen nur ohne dass wir selber das beeinflussen können was soll denn das aber auf sowas wird wahrscheinlich,
hinauslaufen es sei denn es gibt jetzt noch einen großen move hinzu.
Einer Depeche Mode genannten Initiative und aufgeklärten Briten die halt der Meinung sind das,
Volks hatte noch mal befragt wird und nicht nur das Parlament sollte entscheiden und sollte dann eben auch diese drei Möglichkeiten präsentiert bekommen nämlich dir die den heraus gehandelt hat
den wollen wir gar nicht wenn machen notieren gehen trotzdem raus oder wir akzeptieren diesen die den heraus gehandelt habe oder wir ziehen
unsere unseren Austritt zurück so denn die EU und noch haben will was sie natürlich dann wollen würde.
Die EU will Britannien nicht loswerden und das ist großer historische Fehler der da gemacht wird und.
Sollte dir noch verhindert werden können alles die ganze Auseinandersetzung in der Öffentlichkeit,
dreht sich vor allem um die potenziellen Auswirkungen dieses Notdienst Inarius,
also was ist wenn ein wie auch immer ausgehandelter die letzten Endes vom europäischen,
teil oder eben auch von den Briten selbst abgelehnt werden würde so ist es zu keiner Einigung kommt und der Austritt written effect das ist so apokalyptisch was dann passieren würde,
das wird das kann man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen und letzten Endes kann das auch wiederum nicht im Interesse der EU sein weil dann hättest du es halt innerhalb kürzester Zeit mit brennen Mülltonnen zu tun weil dann reden wir nicht mehr über dein Führerschein geht nicht mehr.
Dann reden wir über ganz andere Sachen da reden wir drüber die Nahrungsmittelversorgung bricht zusammen die medica medizinische Versorgung bricht zusammen der komplette komplette Industrie bricht zusammen und zwar innerhalb von Tagen.
Sei einfach den einen als vollständiges Desaster Industries komplett raus weil die aus diesem ganzen ondemand Traffic raus ist,
setzt irgendwie 50 km Staus von irgendwelchen LKWs die alte nicht ordentlich deklariert sind und nichts geht mehr.
Nahrungsmittel Importe Exporte alles nicht mehr möglich Flugzeuge können nicht mehr landen weil es keine keine keine Vereinbarung mehr gibt,
und zwar nicht nur zwischen EU und Britannien sollen generell international wäre auf einmal alles unklar und wenige Unternehmen werden in der Lage das finanziell durchzustehen und dann hättest Du so eine aufschaukelung dieser ganzen Ereignisse also
dann dann würde dieses Land wirklich innerhalb kürzester Zeit einfach
in Flammen steht da sind sich dadurch auch mittlerweile alle einig in alle versuchen diese diese Situation zu vermeiden aber sind sich einfach nur darüber einig wie,
weils halt diese Hardliner gibt die einfach mittlerweile auch fest ja im Prinzip alles auch in diesem trumpismus unterwegs sind die ganze Zeit Lügen dummes Zeug
erzählen und wenn man sich halt anschaut wie dieser ganze brexit Wahlkampf gelaufen ist das hat sich ja mittlerweile auch herausgestellt wer war da mit im Spiel Cambridge analytica alles was wir schon besprochen haben
da wurden irgendwie Facebook Nachrichten gestreut genauso wie das im
amerikanischen Wahlkampf war dir einfach diese ganzen Lügen von wir zahlen ja mehr als wir kriegen und so weiter und die Kohle geht alles zum LS und immigrant sind an allem schuld
das ist genau dasselbe Spiel und man muss ja auch klar machen das ist jetzt nicht so die blöden Briten.
Waren ja schon immer scheiße und jetzt wollen sie weglassen wenn sie doch gehen nein.
Auch da gibt es irgendwie kluge Leute und blöde Leute und dieses Volk ist gerade dabei von so einem rechtsextremen Wahnsinn entführt zu werden,
und sollte Großbritannien dann am Ende dieses Prozesses so eine unkontrollierte Situation lang dann dauert es nicht lange und der Europäer ist an allem schuld.
Und dann haben wir da einfach Feinde und dann schaukelt sich das einfach noch weiter auf und das ist das ist ein Szenario dass ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen also,
wir haben da wirklich ein großes politisches europäisches,
Problem und natürlich muss das verhindert werden da aber keinerlei.
Stabile Regierung existiert mit der man irgendwas normal diskutieren könnte was sind ist was vor allem daran liegt dass sie selber alle nicht wissen was sie eigentlich wollen.
Keine keine Mehrheit für nichts gibt und alles immer noch so unter diesen Vorhang hebt mit naja wer gegen den brexit ist der stellt sich gegen das Volk und es Landesverräter deswegen kommt auch die Opposition nicht aus.
Wer hält das denn irgendwie wer hält das denn warm mit diesem wenn du gegen den brexit bist bisschen landesverräters muss doch ihr also.
Ladi brexiteers volles Programm die Tories Ansicht weil die Tore ist natürlich an einfach Angst haben generell die Macht zu verlieren an Leber in Susanne an diesem Termin Corbin den sie alle hassen wie die Pest weil der ja auch eigentlich in anti-eu Mensch ist nur das ganz anderen Gründen
der sieht das halt aus oder aufgrund sozialistischen Grundhaltung heraus
so ja das ist ja hier alles das große böse Kapital und davon dass wir uns fernhalten aber quasi die Regierung an Leber abzugeben unter der Führung von Jeremy corbyn das ist halt dann die große Angst vom Kommunismus.
So und ne andere Partei ist halt nicht Hinsicht die in um deiner frommen wenn es wert Mehrheiten bekommen kann,
und die Tore sind komplett zerstritten wie schon dargestellt und
sind dich einfach überhaupt nicht grün darüber Teresa mäßig hätte ich die Schwester Regierungschefin seit langen dort weil sie halt einfach noch nicht mal eine eigene Mehrheit hat die die sie hatte hat sie verspielt ja ist angewiesen auf die Stimmen aus Nordirland
und das ist dann dann das nächste Problem was losgeht also Nordirland ist mittlerweile das erste Mal seit 30 Jahren bei Umfragen eine Mehrheit für den Anschluss an Irland.
Was auch jetzt warum die ganz romantisch klingen mag aber wo erstens glaube ich Irland eigentlich gar keinen Bock drauf hat,
sich jetzt auf wie diese Krisenregion da noch einzutreten,
ja die bisher eigentlich schon immer getrennt war und ja ok da oben ist viel trouble aber hier ist ist alles in Ordnung da mitkommt Irland lange Sicht auch nicht hin
die EU würde ja dann sozusagen wieder so ein Krisenherd auch
Nordirland sich dann Irland anschließt und dann in der EU aufgeht wäre dann eben auch wiederum das Ende des United Kingdoms,
und dann dauert eben auch nicht mehr lange und die Schotten drehen auch durch trennen sich wiederum ab dann bleibt nur noch England Wales übrig dann haben wir wiederum die Auseinandersetzung mit,
wo wir Schottland jetzt wieder rein dann sehen die Spanier durch wegen Katalonien und Baskenland die Verkettung sind,
Kinder beliebig weit ist schlimm für alles.
Zugehörigkeit Mut machen.
Wollen wir noch zum Abschluss ein bisschen über schlechte Laune und Hetze in den Netzen reden.
Ja es hat so ein bisschen was damit zu tun und tatsächlich.
Ist das Thema jetzt hier eigentlich nur in unsere Notizen gelandet weil ich diesen Artikel gelesen habe bzw einen Buchauszug den ich war ganz interessant fand das ist ein Buch heißt change your mind geschrieben worden von zwei österreichischen,
Autoren die eine ist also sind beide bei dem plus 4,
Fernsehsender dir diesen ProSiebenSat1 Konglomerat gehört in Österreich unterwegs sie ist Journalisten I irgendwie des CEO,
un
im Prinzip müsste mit dieser These mit was können wir da irgendwie dagegen tun gegen diese ganze Hitze und Fake News im Netz ich habe das Buch jetzt nicht gelesen das ist halt nur ein Auszug im Netz aber das fand ich ihn ganz interessante Geschichte weil,
die Corinna Corinna Milborn da beschreibt wie sie eben auf Facebook von so einem Menschen,
Brandblasen Migrationsdebatte auch beheizt wurde mit ja bei uns mitten in Wien werden Frauen auf der Straße vergewaltigt aber darüber verlieren sie ja kein Wort in den.
Da halten sich alle an die Nachrichtensperre und Schweigen brav damit machen sich mitschuldig ich wünsche ihnen dass ihr am Heimweg überfallen und von einer wildgewordenen Horde Afrikaner vergewaltigt werden dann merken sie vielleicht mal was los ist mit ihren Kulturbereicherer
oder sind sie gleich für immer los das wäre ja noch besser also so harter Tobak so geht's los
und was sie dann aber gemacht hat ist jetzt in dann ausfindig gemacht und das ist halt irgendwie so ein Durchschnittsbürger in Wien so Reihenhaus Pipapo das übliche
mit Kindern und hat die halt direkt damit konfrontiert und natürlich damit auch schon mal total überrascht über die dort ja dann immer denken so oh Gott.
Das sind ja alles nur im Netz Start und wenn dass sie sich dann so in ihrer eigenen Welt auf einmal vorhin entfaltet dann sind sie ja gleich ganz anders drauf und
sie beschreibt wie Sie dann eben die Diskussion gesorgt hat gesucht hat und wie sie sich von ihm mal hat erklären lassen warum man den das alles glaubt und dann ja dann nehme ich ja hier aber auf Facebook untersteht das ja alles,
ist ja hier alles passiert und gucken Sie mal hier ist der Nachrichten Artikel dann haben wir das,
daher recherchiert und festgestellt naja das Facebook-Profil von dem diese Nachrichten weiterverbreitet wurden
allein schon der Avatar taucht irgendwie auf zehn russischen Kontakte Seiten auf und
ist halt einfach ein Fake Avatar die Geschichte hat zwar Zoe nicht stattgefunden aber der Artikel bezog sich überhaupt gar nicht auf Wien sondern bezog sich auf
Deutschland an anstelle cetera et cetera und beschreibt wie bei diesem Menschen dann so ein Prozess Einsätze so oh mann sie haben mich verarscht wie konnte ich nur und dann auch so ein entsprechendes Charme dabei rauskommen.
Warum finde ich das so interessant weil in unserer Debatte das glaube ich immer auch sehr leicht fällt.
Den Leuten die diesen Trend somit anheizen aber gleich pauschal zur Unterstützten zu unterstellen sie hätten halten niedere Motive und in dem Fall,
natürlich jetzt nicht wieder Typ sonst so drauf ist nur es hat sich dann eben bei ihm auch so einen Sinneswandel eingestellt und mittlerweile sieht er das eben auch ganz anders und.
Versucht auch andere Leute darauf hinzuweisen ob diese Fake News ist dann selber Opfer geworden wiederum im letzten wurde von anderen dann bestimmt weil er dagegen gehalten hat und zeigt halt auch wie hilflos glaube ich viele in unserer Gesellschaft sind.
Jeder Konfrontation mit diesen überbordenden selbst sich verstärkenden Nachrichtenstrom.
Nicht nur Facebook auf Twitter ist auch generell alles und dann na ja schon öfter drüber gesprochen.
Ja und denke man sollte zumindest dich.
Bericht ja auch mal durchlesen selber mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken weil alle sind irgendwie hilflos aber ich denke es,
gibt auch schon noch Möglichkeiten dem etwas entgegenzusetzen das erfordert bloß mehr direkte Interaktion so mit den Leuten die wir kennen in der Firma,
in der Familie im näheren bekannten ja.
Oder liest man so komische Artikel wie Polizei ermittelt weil ein Student ein Postillon Artikel liked und.
Da dachte ich schon so a wieder ein geiler Artikel von vom Postillion.
Der ist aber schafft irgendwie noch mal so eine fette rauszufinden aber wie schon bei Herrn Maassen er wo er auch um den Tag vorher der Postillon Soja AFD zieht V-Mann außen.
Offenbach.
Aus dem Verfassungsschutz auch so und das wäre dann Maassen Sonntag später dann halt die Meldung die wir schon diskutiert haben wo man sich halt auch denkt ok also wenn jetzt ein Postillon Artikel nur noch 1 Tag hält dann ist ob wir auch was Cup.
Das war halt auch so ein so ein Artikel,
im Passion hier du machst mich nichts als Ärger Björn höcke dreht Hitler Foto auf seinem Nachttisch um.
Den Ungarn Student das lustig fahren und den dann geliked hat und damit taucht er das natürlich dann wieder in all diesen ganzen strömen auf und das hat dann wie die Polizei bemerkt und hat dann erstmal gegen diesen Studenten ermittle deswegen.
Weil ja dann Nazisymbole quasi in der Timeline auftauchten weil du likest denen wird der irgendwo automatisch gekreppt das
Foto eingeblendet etc und schon bis ein Ermittlungsverfahren am Hals und ihn hat mir wahrscheinlich schon mal wegen der anderen Geschichte auch schon mal im Netz.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal weil er dann.
Was hat derselbe Student oder wann es jetzt zwei Stunden ist bin ich mir gerade gerade gar nicht so ganz sicher auf jeden Fall der andere Fall ist das eben auch einfach nur das weiterverteilen eines Beitrags des Bayerischen Rundfunks wo halten,
Fahne von so einer ypg also von dieser bewaffneten arms der PKK mit im Bild war weil das eben auch auf der Facebook-Seite auftauchte und weiter alles.
Deine Wahnsinn wir haben wirklich immer noch das Problem dass alle Beteiligten ziellos umherirren und nicht wissen was sie tun teilweise mit Vorsatz vielleicht auch teilweise auch.
Tja und das Zerstörer leider auch so in den in den,
immer mehr online na also ich weiß jetzt wie oft schwierig zu sagen so ja war das was vielleicht auch online schon immer Kacke ne das.
Oder vielleicht hat sich auch die eigene Aufmerksamkeit dahin verschoben aber irgendwie hat man doch das Gefühl dass ich doch irgendwie,
online etwas geändert hat.
Oder das online,
etwas geändert hat und dass wir glaube ich auch selber lange Zeit einfach das Ende selber nicht wahrhaben wollten hat es auch schon mal erwähnt hätte irgendwann mal so Chaosradio vor langer Zeit mal eine meiner letzten Sendung bin ich sogar die letzte sind ich da gemacht habe,
Twitter Demokratie visioni war noch so voll so arabischer Frühling und so,
Sauser Berufs Optimismus oh ja und wenn dann erstmal die Wahrheit ans Licht kommt und dann sich die die Massen verbünden und dann wird alles toll und danach kam irgendwie Syrien Krieg und jetzt eben auch dieser ganze fake-news Wahnsinn,
bestellen halt Festo wir werden ihr Opfer hier unsere Algorithmen uns hatten,
was ein bisschen so ein Zauberlehrlings Moment und auch gerade bei den Leuten den wir so schnell vorwerfen oder glaubt aber an Verschwörungstheorien sagen auch so einen Computer kreisen.
Uns hilft jemand vor gewöhnen Verschwörungstheorien glauben.
Das kann ich nicht formuliert habe aber was ich meine ist die,
wir werfen anderen Leuten vor dass sie an Verschwörungstheorien glauben und sag dem Motto du bist ja doof weil du glaubst ja an sowas und ja mal eben bei dieser Geschichte aus Österreich gesehen.
Ja
Das kann Verschwörungstheorie aber so dieses Glauben an falsche Berichterstattung weil sie sich auch immer wieder verstärkt und wenn man das einmal liest dann kriegt man ja auch von dem Algorithmus immer wieder weitere Sachen die ähnlich sind vorgeworfen und die Nazis nutzen das natürlich einfach um dann ihre ganze
Lügenpropaganda der Stelle auch noch weiter in diese Kanäle zu pumpen und nutzen das einfach viel intelligenter.
Was ist wirklich meine die Idee des,
in Wiener Einkaufsstraße am laufenden Band Frauen vergewaltigt werden und die Presse da nicht drüber berichtet die ist wirklich ganz schön absurd.
Ja aber sie wird.
Zweimal so wie wenig Ahnung musst du denn von Presse haben wenn wir mal überlegt den Bericht.
Die würde sich doch kein Schmierblatt und kein auch kein anderes Medium entgehen lassen das ist also ich meine muss man ganz ehrlich sagen dass.
Ja pass auf weil alle deine Freunde oder vermeintlichen Freunde das auch sagen.
Unternommen dann dann normiert das einfach deine Wahrnehmung weil du du bist das was in deinem Umfeld der der der Konsens ist dass das.
Das ist so war er.
Dass das ist halt einfach die Wahrheit gerade deswegen haben ja Leute die in seinem Umfeld auch groß werden tierische Probleme sich davon überhaupt erstmal zu lösen.
Egal was das für merkwürdige Glaubenssysteme sind meine geh mal hier zu den Zeugen Jehovas und versuch dann mal irgendwie für Klarheit zu sorgen und das Planet nicht irgendwie wieder an und eintopfen Datum und.
Ich weiß gar nicht woran die gelaufen.
Ja das weiß auch keiner.
Seitenersetzung Glück ruhig die singen ja wenigstens nicht wenn die da am Bahnhof stehen also die finden die stehen halt ein bisschen im Weg aber.
Na gut aber dann hast du halt da die Diabetiker.
Mich in der Kommentarspalte.
Ja gut aber dann hast du die dianetika also es gibt ja überall diese ganzen Glaubensgruppen die irgendwie Leute da in ihren
Glaubens Welpen festhalten und davon abhalten irgendwie da das Licht zu sehen und jetzt haben wir halt durch diesen ganzen online Wahnsinn dann noch weitere Verstärker in den ich die Leute
verfangen so und ich worauf ich hinaus wollte ist ich kann das auch ein Stück weit.
Verstehen und ich sag auch gerade was zu Verschwörungstheorien und sowas betrifft und dieses naja man weiß ja nicht wer da noch dahinter ist und so weiter das ist auch etwas was alte Nerd Kreisen ja auch nicht selten sehr spielerisch,
ja aber schon auch mit mit mit mit Rollos betrieben wurde also dieses,
ja es gibt halt immer noch die Nachricht hinter der Nachricht und dann gibt's noch die richtige Wahrheit und so weiter und ist ja auch was dran ja man muss ja auch die Möglichkeit haben hinter eine nachrichtenberichterstattung zuschauen das tun wir ja hier auch,
unser Diskurs ist ja auch davon geprägt wir schauen halt was ich alles Bericht wir schauen was dargestellt wird wir schauen versuche noch dahinter zu schauen und.
Das ist muss nicht immer eine Verschwörung sein die man dort macht auch muss ich ja auch darin trainieren hinter die Kulissen zu schauen das Predigen wir auch,
so das glauben aber dann viele Leute auch dass sie das tun
das da irgendein System am Werk ist das da Nachrichten unterdrückt werden dass die tagesschau irgendwie durch einen großen System Kraken gesteuert wird um uns irgendwie Informationen vorzuhalten glauben sie halt einfach und,
da müssen wir in gesellschaftlichen Diskurs finden der hier wieder Ordnung rein bringt ist manchmal nicht so richtig wo ich an.
Also das war eine vorsichtige Feststellung ne aber ich habe diese Sachen auch irgendwann einmal gelernt ne also mir wurde das ja beigebracht.
Slice vielleicht ich kann damit ich kann mich jetzt nicht konkret daran erinnern.
Wann ich ja doch weiß ich sogar reichen also da war ich wahrscheinlich im Gymnasium als ich mich mit oder da war ich auf dem Gymnasium als ich mich mit Journalismus und sowas auseinandergesetzt habe.
Entsprechende Dinge irgendwie besucht habe wo man sich damit auseinandersetzt beim das beigebracht wird und vieles gibt eben Dinge die,
damit meine ich jetzt prinzipiell erstmal so zu eine eine.
Eine Information in ihrer Kredibilität einzuschätzen ja also ein einfaches Beispiel jemand veröffentlicht ein Video.
Und ein irgendein Nazi.
Also oder so sagen wir mal Hans Georg Maaßen sag dann dieses Video ist eine Fälschung ja jetzt muss klar sein dass es ein Weg nach vorne gibt dieses.
Aufzuklären.
Und vor allem muss klar sein dass es notwendig ist dieses aufzuklären weil die reine Behauptung von egal wem eben nicht reicht man muss.
Alles in in im Prinzip darauf prüfen anzweifeln und unten Belege verlangen Quellen suchen und man kann nicht sagen ja der und der hat dieses oder jenes gesagt dass das wird dann jetzt schon stimmen.
Ja und dieses dieses kritische Denken ist ganz klar musst den Leuten.
Beigebracht werden das ist auch im Wert für sich aber das ist eben auch ein Handwerk.
Und jetzt hast du irgendwie jetzt haben inzwischen hat sich rumgesprochen dass es sinnvoll ist kritisch zu denken und jetzt hast du Leute die können das nicht.
Und meine ganzen Tag in die durch die Gegend sagen sie windet sich kritisch denken ich bin heute ich bin aber jetzt hier und Querdenker hast du dir mal erzähl mal wenn du die Leute anschaust die sich selber als Querdenker bezeichnen.
Starte den einer die relativ lange schon ziemlich Querdenken sowie das ist also das ist halt ein ein Handwerk und das muss muss beigebracht werden.
Und ich führe sowieso am Ende viele viele Probleme in unserer Gesellschaft letztendlich auf die Bildungspolitik zurück.
Vielleicht habe ich da auch ein beides in der rechnen dass ich eigentlich jeden Rezept vielleicht sage okay,
dass ich das für übermäßig wichtig halte das Leute eine Bildung bekommt kann sein aber ich würde mich echt eher fragen so was.
Haben wir versäumt bei Menschen die sich idividi wir Ihnen die in eine Realität geschickt haben.
Wo
Muss ich so ein Bussi so ein Stuss glauben ja wo sie das ist für mich eine eine Art von bin der niemanden zu nah treten aber es ist eine Art von off von Eis,
ja wie finde ich das jetzt wie finde ich einen schönen Begriff für von einem Defizit.
Jade das im in der Wahrnehmung Umdenken im Leben ja wenn man.
Soll ich mal nicht in der Lage ist,
sinnvoll wenn man die Mittel nicht an die Hand gegeben bekommen hat sinnvoll das Geschehen was um einen herum stattfindet
einzuordnen zu bewerten und zu eben zu schauen a-ok Pass auf die Behauptung auf der Einkaufsstraße wären am laufenden Band Leute vergewaltigt,
deckt sich nicht mit meiner Erfahrung.
Und wenn das wahr wäre wie würde sich die Realität Verhalten ja also sind das so zu überlegen so ist es eine realistische Annahme dass es eine Nachrichtensperre gibt.
Überbestimmte Informationen und wie würde die Welt aussehen wenn es wenn die wenn diese Informationen tatsächlich zutreffend ist eine Nachrichtensperre aber.
Nicht existiert würde z.b. eine Bild-Zeitung z.b. sofort darüber berichten oder halte ich es für realistisch dass,
Julian Reichelt,
linksgrün versiffte Verschwörungen eingegangen ist um um die Welt um vor der Welt zu verheimlichen dass im laufenden Band,
Siri wie Vergewaltigung stattfinden so da gibt's doch irgendwo dem Moment wo
wo wir hoffen würden dass Menschen sagen moment mal ich bin ich kann jetzt Diesel ich kann jetzt hypothetisch mir vorstellen,
was alles an an Verschwörung notwendig wäre und ich kann das prüfen und ich kann am Ende dann sagen okay das ist eine nicht belegte und auch nicht belegbare Behauptung wieder getätigt wurde.
Und das ist ein Mindestmaß und das muss auch jeder jeder einzelne Mensch selber bauen weil es ist genauso wenig,
akzeptabel wenn Leute sagen naja okay Tim und Linus haben aber jetzt gesagt in Wien werden keine Leute vergewaltigt die wir wissen dass sie mir auch nicht,
flat ist das Sodom und Gomorra Tim und wir fliegen da irgendwie ein paar Wochen hin vielleicht sollten wir vielleicht sollte man es das noch mal überlegen das war aber Frauen Kinder zu Hause.
Gut aber ich meine wir würden ja jetzt z.b. auch davon ausgehen dass du eine Situation in der Türkei derzeit sehr wohl am startest oder in irgendwelchen,
arabischen Staaten sehr sehr wohl ein System am Status was bestimmte nachricht systematisch.
An ihrer Verbreitung hindert.
Ja aber auch sogar dort und das ist glaube ich der beste Beispiel sogar dort wo Mensch wo es solche Regime gibt.
Ja hast du Menschen.
Die dagegen arbeiten daran vorbei arbeiten und die dann in mit mit drakonischen Strafen überzogen werden,
ja selbst da wo du für eine für irgendwie investigativen Journalismus und Kritik am am Herrscher wirklich in Knast Landes ja wir dürfen nicht vergessen ja Peter steudtner noch nicht so lange zurück,
und den der der Vorsitze von M ist hinter der Schnee ganze Zeit die wir hatten ja selbst da wo Menschen.
Oder was weiß ich Mexico City wo Menschen Mexiko wo Menschen verschwunden werden.
Ja da wird einfach Kupfer weg so selbst da gibt es Menschen die damit an die Öffentlichkeit treten.
Ja aber wenn nimmt die Öffentlichkeit war also ich meine innerhalb der Türkei da können wir uns jetzt überhaupt gar nicht so richtig vorstellen wie da Nachrichten dieser Art Wort noch kommen oder heißt es dann ja terrorunterstützer und so weiter Staatsstreiche Supporter ist etterer.
Daran arbeiten dass dass wir dass wir diese Nachrichten bekommen können tschuldigung das muss ja kurz ausführen daran arbeiten die hier die ganze Zeit.
Naja also unsere Community mit Salz mit verschlüsselten Messengern sei es mit mit.
Ist alles in Ordnung ich sage ja nur.
Wir nehmen wahr aus anderen Ländern dass da so eine Situation auch da ist und über die wird ja auch Bericht.
Dass man in eine Situation sich selber bringen lassen kann wo man dann glaubt das kann bei uns dann auch so sein absolut nachvollziehbar.
Nachvollziehbar klar Arbeiten wieder gegen Klaas leben wir beide jetzt auch in einem etwas denken wir zumindest aufgeklärt drin Umfeld,
da wo wir eine Etwas ungefilterte Wahrnehmung der Realität haben in unserer Sichtweise einen guten Blick auf.
Nee ich finde es.
Ist geschehen aber.
Zudem werden wir gleich wieder in die Kommentare wir haben nicht einen ungefilterter run Blick auf die Realität wir haben einen wir haben eine Möglichkeit,
festzumachen dass das was wir sehen Realität ist und das zu trennen von dem was vielleicht nicht Realität ist das mag vielleicht noch Dinge geben die es gibt viele Dinge die in dieser Realität existieren die ich nicht verstehe oder die ich nur gefehlt hat wahrnehme
aber ich habe zumindestens Verständnis davon was Realität ist und was nicht.
Und das ist glaube ich der entscheidende Unterschied nicht jeder der der irgendwie rechten Theorien anhängt ist ist gleichzeitig ein Idiot.
Ja es gibt auch sehr geskippt kluge Nazis entscheidend ist,
dass wir dass wir wenn wir wenigstens also wenn man schon solche Theorien,
wenn man solchen Theorien anhängt dann wenigstens auf auf irgendwie belegbar auf Basis von belegbaren Informationen natürlich kannst du.
Keine Ahnung eine eine Position vertreten gegen das für das eu-leistungsschutzrecht ja aber es wäre.
Meine Erwartung ist das dann ein Argument vorgetragen wird dafür dass
dem lachtest standhält wenn es den lacht Test besteht dann akzeptiere ich einen Menschen auch als Kommunikationspartner
ja und wenn man man kann sich sicherlich kritisch über Migration
unterhalten man kann sich da man kann ja Nein informierten Austausch treten über jeden Sachverhalt und man kann für beide Seiten oder für alle Dimensionen auf den man auf ein sachfeld blicken kann.
Argumente finden.
Aber die sollten halt schon mit den Sachverhalt zu tun haben und da gibt es eben einen Unterschied zwischen Realität und nicht Realität.
Und den zu erkennen ist
notwendig ist ein bisschen Bedingungen für die Teilnahme an einer Demokratie und finde für die Bereicherung auch und für die finde finde finde autonome selbständiges für selbständiges Denken und auch für eine Wehrhaftigkeit
unseres Gesellschaftssystems gegen.
Wie auch immer geartete äußere oder innere Einflüsse und da,
sehe ich tatsächlich massives Versäumnisse dich den Personen überhaupt nicht anlassen anlasten würde.
Welcher die Versäumnisse gab es sicherlich nicht nur die Bildung und im Ostendorfer noch mal speziell die Situation nach der Wende ja war auch dazu geführt hat dass er viele Leute einfach gegangen sind.
Im Osten natürlich auch die die Erfahrung fährst du gesehen hast du ja doch,
der kann sein dass uns der ganzen Stadt verarschen und unterdrücken will das ja das gibt und das gibt das man selbst seinem nächsten nicht mehr trauen kann das ist für für Menschen mit dieser Erfahrung natürlich eine ganz andere.
Systemwechsel kann jederzeit wieder stattfinden und wieso alle 40 Jahre ist es soweit.
Gut dass wir jetzt weiter als ursprünglich gedacht aber vielleicht auch mal eine interessante Zwischenrufer mit dennoch Nachrichten.
Wir haben Kurzmeldungen lieber Tim,
und zwar machen wir hier einmal kurz Werbung unsere Freunde bei epicenter works haben eine Stelle ausgeschrieben zwar am,
11. September hasse diese Stellenausschreibung veröffentlicht bei epicenter works ihr wisst das ist
die führende österreichische NGO für die Stärkung von Grund und Freiheitsrechte im digitalen Zeitalter.
Thomas Lohninger der ja hier regelmäßig auch zuhören ist hat diese was macht er welche Position hat er nicht erfüllt diese Organisation ne.
Und die suchen jetzt ein Ende.
Position als Communications Manager Junior Senior Geschlecht egal du bist,
Delta Netzpolitik Menschenrechte Gerechtigkeit motiviert in dieser Welt etwas zu verändern und eine Stimme der Zivilgesellschaft zu sein und du bist gut darin komplexe Inhalte einfach und zielgruppengerecht auf zu bearbeiten in Texten Bildern und oder Medien wirksamen.
Inszenierungen du bist textsicher in Deutschland englischer Sprache sein und erfahren in Social Media klassische Medienarbeit und ideal war idealerweise auch politischen Kampagnen dann,
gibt es hier für dich hoffentlich den,
das Ziel an diesem Bewerbungsverfahren teilzunehmen du bekommst geboten ein Dienstort im Herzen sehen.
Ja kannst dich dann kannst du direkt noch feststellen ob da am laufenden Band Vergewaltigung stattfinden oder nicht ja dann bildet sich doch die Möglichkeit der Sache selber zu auf den Grund zu gehen
Tätigkeit im Rahmen von 20 bis 40 Wochenstunden möglich sind sowohl eine Anstellung als auch ein Beratungsvertrag du solltest noch dieses Jahr einsteigen können idealerweise Oktober-November.
Und geboten wird der eine Bezahlung die sich im ferengie aus üblichen Rahmen bewegt weil je nach Qualifikation und Erfahrungen.
Wenn ich das interessiert wenn du dich angesprochen fühlst findest du den Link in den shoutout und kannst dann schon bald,
mit Thomas zusammen arbeiten ich kann nicht oft genug betonen Thomas hat da inzwischen echten Track-Record.
Galopp zum Netzneutralität geht egal ob es um Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht epicenter works bzw die Vorgänger Organisation der,
AK Vorrat Österreich haben da durchaus schon das ein oder andere die ein oder andere Kerbe.
Marke Gesetz genau dem ist ja auch mehr mehr Thomas weil du wirst ein wenig aussteigen für ein paar Wochen und dann gibt's immer ein bisschen Alternativprogramm unter anderem,
mit Thomas aber nicht nur kann man noch hier Kurzmeldungen EU ja.
Also das Thema finde ich tatsächlich relativ interessant ich setze mich ja in in meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit in verschiedenen Bereichen.
Auch mit der Übermacht von Google Apple Facebook Facebook Facebook und.
Und Amazon genannt Gaffa auseinander.
Und diese Übermacht dieser Konzerne ist natürlich,
in einem wird eine Suppe aßen das Ausmaß angenommen dass wir ja in hier inzwischen die Netzneutralität auch von wollen um unsere Netzbetreibern noch irgendwie Möglichkeiten zur.
Zur zur Monetarisierung zu bieten die haben viele Geschäftsmodelle oder Konkurrenz Geschäftsmodell die intim auf die irgendjemand noch kommen könnte längst in der Tasche die haben das Geld um diese Nacht
dauerhaft zu sichern ja also,
bestes Beispiel wenn wenn irgendwann einmal jemand auf die Idee kommt ein Produkt.
Zu entwickeln eine App zu entwickeln die die dann noch in der Lage ist die vielleicht.
Diese treten Konzerne zu überholen wie Beispiel,
Instagram oder Whatsapp dann kaufen die sich das einfach und die haben das Geld sich das zu kaufen das etwas was wir auch über die Jahrzehnte auch bei Microsoft beobachtet haben ja.
Und noch dazu.
Hanna ist diese überwacht der Konzerne dadurch gekennzeichnet dass sie in dieser globalisierten Welt zu sehen ihre Dienstleistungen dort zu versteuern wo sie besondere Konditionen haben das heißt.
Wird nicht großartig infn Wirtschaft Ideen.
Abwandern aber ist ist es schon immer auch von denen Wirtschaft liberalsten wird dann schon argumentiert,
das so ein großer Konzern ja nichts schlechtes ist und wenn der viel mehr Wirtschaft und viel Gewinn scheffelt und uns ein iPhone für 1600 € anbietet das da immer noch was gutes bei rumfeld weil diese Konzerne ja irgendwo Menschen,
anstellen oder Steuern zahlen und in irgendeiner Form auf dem geweint Gemeinwesen dienen und hier gibt es eben bei diesem.
Konzernen inzwischen dann doch auf EU-Ebene Zweifel dass das noch der Fall.
Und da wirds gibt es jetzt erste Bestrebungen sich zu überlegen wie man denn am 4,
einen feedback loop in das Gemeinwohl seid das europäische sei es dass jeweils nur nationale in irgendeiner Form sicherstellen könnte denn die Stau
auf digitale Geschäfte beträgt so ungefähr.
Während EU üblich so eigentlich 23% zu erwarten wäre wären wie der österreichische Finanzminister Hartwig löger.
Kritisiert unten natürlich.
Zieht er auch sofort den sinnvollen Schluss ne wenn der in Österreich an der Regierung ist dann ist nicht schwer zu erraten wes Geistes Kind er ist insofern hat er dann schon mal ein gutes Beispiel genommen hat sich einen Europe first,
Button an den Kopf geklebt nee Andi weiß nicht wo der sich denn hingekriegt.
Monster Wer Warschau.
Lösche ich ans Gewehr und wird nun für eine härtere Gangart.
Ja trumpismus in Reinkultur das,
ist natürlich alles bedränge ich habe so ein bisschen gestutzt als ich die Nachrichten dazu gelesen hatte somit diesen 23%,
ich denke diese Einschätzung ist so zeigen die Gesamtbelastung die zusammenkommen bei Anwendung aller Ertragssteuern also das wird sich ja dann,
glücklicherweise für Unternehmen aus körperschaftssteuern und Gewerbesteuern,
zusammen und die ganze Debatte darüber wie man denn jetzt ein Unternehmen besteuern kann was in diese klassischen Steuermodelle kann ich mir so richtig reinpasst weil das ja eben von so einer lokalen Präsenz ausgeben hat immer gesagt ja ein Unternehmen ist ja immer irgendwo.
Einerseits ist es irgendwo in einer Gemeinde ja,
Zeit dort Lokal Gewerbesteuern worüber die Gemeinden dann halt auch in so einem offenen Wettbewerb reingehen kann was auch nicht unbedingt immer besonders gut funktioniert andererseits auf Staatsebene hat man diese körperschaftssteuern wo dann eben diese Erträge auch,
abgegriffen werden sprich wenn ein Unternehmen gut verdient
dann verdient auch der Starter dran alle glücklich alles super alles toll und innerhalb der EU ist das halt jetzt einerseits dadurch schon ins Wanken gekommen
weil eben über diese Steuersätze hier einige europäischer Wettbewerb gemacht wird das haben wir zum Beispiel gesehen Irland jawo Apple durch zahlreiche Konstruktion aber auch andere Unternehmen Luxemburg Amazon z.b.
Einfach immer wieder genau die Konstruktion gewählt hat die für das jeweilige Geschäftsmodell optimal ist
unser letzten Endes die tatsächliche Steuerlast so weit zu reduzieren bis ins absolut bist du irgendwie auf null.
Das spielt ja viel mit rein Umsatzsteuer Realitäten wie das alles miteinander verrechnet wird und welche Förderungsmöglichkeiten es gibt
aber ist ja jetzt auch gerade gegen Irland dieser Prozess angestrebt worden und sieht auch schon erste Verurteilung das Irland hier falsch gehandelt hat und Geld zurückfordern muss von Apple,
also ganzen Sachen und jetzt versucht man halt eben zu überlegen wie können wir denn unsere,
Butter prallität und damit auch unsere Steuerrelais steht an die Gegebenheiten des Internetzeitalters anpassen und,
die Debatte wird für meinen Geschmack auch noch nicht breit genug geführt weil es derzeit wird es natürlich alles so als ja da kommt da die böse EU kommt die böse USA mit ihren Konzernen EC die Auswirkungen sind natürlich noch weiter über Google und,
Facebook und andere hinaus und wenn es demnächst auch mit China sehen mit Alibaba und im großen Konzern der dahinter steht und vielleicht eben auch.
Mit uns selber ja so vielleicht gelingt ja auch der EU irgendwann noch mal so internationaler Erfolg und nun muss ich halt auch fragen wie passen wir das eben an wann wann ist ein
Unternehmen Steuerpflicht der Gedanke der sich jetzt glaube ich hier so ein bisschen durchsetzt ist du machst hier Geld in unserem Land egal wo du bist dann wollen wir was daran verdienen und,
David habe ich verschiedene Ansätze entweder an die Attraktion ranzugehen oder an die Umsatzsteuern einiges ich tu auf jeden Fall nicht.
Großen Länder die die sozusagen auch viel präsent haben Deutschland Frankreich,
die sind natürlich dafür so eine Steuer einzuführen sind digitalsteuer die kleineren Länder.
Irland Finnland Itera oder ihm auch die kleinste Länder sprich Malta,
Luxemburg Literat ist immer ihre ihren Weg in der EU gesehen haben um hiermit erhalten indem Sie angepasste Steuermodelle für bestimmte Wirtschaftsvertreter anzubieten.
Sind nicht ganz so begeistert so eine Strafe nur kommen wenn es ja Einheit gibt und dass es derzeit noch nicht abzusehen dass es darauf,
hinausläuft davon abgesehen wird eben auch in
Wirtschafts Kreisen bezweifelt ob dir das so eine gute Idee ist nicht weil letzten Endes das was heute für Facebook und Google gut funktioniert und die als Bedrohung gesehen wird würde eben durchaus auch Geschäftsmodelle für unsere eigene Industrie sein und wenn man sitzt hier gleich
wieder Steuern einfällt an der Stelle wo es wiederum Wachstum verhindert könnte das auch nach hinten losgehen ich kann das,
schwer nachvollziehen weil wir da einfach die Gesetzmäßigkeiten Wirtschaft Leben nicht so bekannt sind aber teilweise gibt's die Einschätzung dass das Ganze aus einem Bumerang Effekt.
Na also interessant ist du kannst natürlich nicht eine Steuer machen die sagte wir bestellen jetzt Google Apple Amazon und Facebook sondern du,
muss dann eine lad Geschäftstätigkeit definieren ja und da wird jetzt gerade geplant zusammen er ok Verkaufs und Werbeeinnahmen im Internet,
aber auch Erlöse aus dem Verkauf von Kundendaten bzw aus der Monetarisierung von Kundendaten,
und dann planen Sie bis ja ab 750 Millionen Euro Jahresumsatz oder sowas wollen wir mal schauen aber hast du dich sofort die Bedenkenträger ja vW will ebenfalls mit Kundendaten handeln und da haben sie natürlich irgendwie keinen
sind sie nicht so motiviert da jetzt irgendwie auch noch Geld für zu bezahlen zahlen zu müssen wie sowie die Steuer soll uns auch treffen und,
ansonsten scheint Olaf Scholz wohl zu fürchten dass Donald Trump irgendwie knatschig wird wenn so was gemacht wird den Handels den WAV den Waffenstillstand im Handelskrieg mit den USA,
wenn man jetzt möglichst beibehalten und den nicht stören ja also ich das.
Ich glaube wir haben es einfach mal mit in die Sendung aufgenommen weil das jetzt zum ersten mal diskutiert wird und ich bin ja mal gespannt,
ob wir ob das etwas wird was wir vielleicht über die Jahre hier im Logbuch begleiten können,
bin halt auch gespannt wie sie das jetzt auch dann am Ende wieder verkacken wollen weil da wird ihm bestimmt eine Möglichkeit einfallen.
Ja hier fehlt glaube ich die ganze Politik
politikwissenschaftliche Debatte um Sinn und Nutzen von so etwas und wir sowas in der Zukunft mal aufgestellt werden sollte das jetzt auch jetzt bei der Urheberrechts Debatte sehr geholfen
oder habe ich da heute was gibt es dass wir da schnell vorankommt da hier Einigkeit erzielt werden muss zwischen einen starten glaube ich wenn wir das so schnell nicht sehen.
Und das würde ich sagen bringt uns zu den Terminen.
Vom 28 bis 30 September 2018 findet in der TU Berlin im mathegebäude die Fiscon statt die jährliche glaube ich Konferenz,
ist es dieses Mal mit dem Titel Brave New World Gestaltungsfreiheit and und macht Muster soziotechnischer Systeme.
Samstag habe ich bisschen was zu sagen viele Produkte Entwicklung und Einsatzfelder der Informatik scheinen sich unausweichlich.
Technisch notwendig so entwickelt zu haben wie wir sie heute kennen und dem wird dir widersprochen denn so.
Das FIS es gibt immer verschiedene Wege ein Problem anzugehen und entsprechend Ressourcen,
für dessen Lösung aufzuwenden Programm und Speaker findet ihr in den shoutouts oder unter 20 18.5 com.de werden in den nächsten Tagen dann,
auch noch die Titel und weitere Teile des Programms bekanntgegeben.
Untere große Überraschung und ich sag mal you heard it here first nein.
Nee das haben wir schon veröffentlicht.
Echt na ja.
Sei nicht so der 35 Karlsruhe location Kongress der 25 C3 Wirtschaft finden keine Überraschung in Leipzig,
Ponte das ne ganze natürlich wieder zum festen Datum dem 27-30 Dezember 2018 und der Call for Papers ist herausgekommen.
Ab jetzt gibt es die Möglichkeit Einreichung zu machen für Torx in den diesmal 6 checks,
und die sechs Jacksons art & culture SX society and politics hardwarerat making,
Security silence & resilience und Detox sollten in der Regel 30 Minuten sein zehn minuten und wenn ja Mehrbedarf habt könnt ihr euch für einen 45 Minuten + 15 minuten Slot,
bewerben und dieses ich hab so den Eindruck du bist bei SX society and politics etwas mehr involviert.
Bitte noch mal die Pfanne für Villen.
Ja ich glaube also alle Tracks sind beautiful ja aber natürlich ethics society and politics first.
Es gibt zu jedem einzelnen Track ausführliche Beschreibung was da drin wie was sich darunter vorgestellt wird insbesondere jetzt bei Resilienz.
Vielleicht auch nicht jedem sofort ein wofür dieses Wort genau steht.
Deswegen bitte wenn ihr da eine Einreichung vorhabt dann lies den call for participation und dieser Mission guidelines vollständig da steht drin welche Informationen wir von euch erwarten da steht für jeden Track drin,
was sich da gewünscht wird welche Art von Einreichung man da haben möchte aber da erwartet werden und da wird dann auch noch,
erklärt dass wir ein neues pro neues Kontingent quasi haben für foundations Torx also für Einsteiger Torx,
Google.
Auf die Gefahr hin dass ich im Kontext eines CCC Congress ist auch mal zu wiederholen auch noch mal im Überblick.
Modern Einstieg für ein Thema zu bieten.
Dieser Mission guidelines sind nicht umsonst recht ausführlich und wir würden uns wünschen dass ihr die.
Ziemlich genau euch zu Herzen nimmt was da alles zu formuliert wurde und dass wir alles Neues haben das spart.
Euch vielleicht den.
Berger einer Ablehnung uns aber vielleicht auch den Ärger und passende Einreichungen und anschauen zu müssen denn,
die Konkurrenz bei diesem Kongress ist immer enorm hoch kann jetzt schon sagen die Wahrscheinlichkeit hier angenommen zu den Rhein die rechnerische ja Anzahl Einreichung Anzahl Slots ist dem sehr gering,
da muss man sich durch eine besondere Einreichung eben.
Auch hervortun und muss mit einer starken Konkurrenz rechnen und das schafft man am besten wenn man sich genau durchgelesen hat worauf da geachtet.
Also lohnt sich auch aus eigener Erfahrung sagen habe jetzt den letzten Jahren hier nicht so viel teilgenommen aber auch hier und da also immer wieder teilweise erschreckend,
wie nachlässig hier dein eigener Sache gearbeitet wird obwohl es so schwierig letzlich auch nicht ist einfach mal klar zusammenzufassen was man eigentlich vorhat was man erzählen will und und welcher Prämisse man das.
Und vor allem oder salihaus wird das Signal was man so als wäre dann ja auch als erstes bekommt wenn ihr noch nicht meiner Lage seid das irgendwie für eine Jury zusammenzufassen.
Was soll dann erst aus dem Topf werden und deswegen ist der erste Eindruck an dieser Stelle entscheiden.
Jo dann müssen wir diese Sendung auch zum Ende führen mein Freund.
Ja das heißt wir wir danken noch schnell und zwar einmal würde ich gerne der wieb Gedanken und dem Ricardo.
Und ich danke einfach malen die dazu beitragen dass nicht alles noch schlimmer wird und hoffen dass wir in der nächsten Sendung wieder eine gute Nachricht für euch haben.
Was ist noch drin sein.
Ich habe ja es gibt ja eine gute Nachrichten.
Haben und zwar habe ich ja wie angekündigt mit Christian zusammen im Kohlenpott Podcast Geschichte geschrieben.
Kohlenstaub gewedelt.
Es gab ja dann noch hier irgendwie,
Verlinkungen in unseren Kommentaren wo auch mal jemand mit einem Aufnahmegerät in einen Keller gegangen ist aber und oder in Salzstock oder sowas her und dann gesagt dass es auch unter Tage ich ja,
aber eben nicht 1200m da war eig.
Unfall nicht Kohlebergbau ich meine man kann es ja auch darauf Oma einschränken.
Nee muss man nicht das ist da ich mach das einfach nur in der Tiefe fest wir haben mit dem wir haben mit der.
Achso.
Das macht also wir haben dort gepackt KZs war eine wirklich,
sehr interessante Erfahrung ich hatte ja schon bisschen berichtet wir haben den wir mussten mit einem explosionsgeschützten Aufnahmegerät dort arbeiten wir sind mit dem
Förderkorb gefahren 42 kmh Fahrstuhl schnellste Fahrstuhl.
Europas und vermutlich auch der weiß ich nicht genau längste weiß ich nicht genau der noch in Betrieb ist oder gibt's Häuser die über 1200 Meter hoch sind.
Die haben nicht durchgehende Fahrstuhl.
Dann bin ich durch den Fahrstuhl der ist wirklich durchgehend sehr spannend und da wir aber eben unter so.
Doch Herr herausfordernde Bedingungen mit diesem analogen explosionsgeschützten Aufnahmegerät gearbeitet haben.
Wird sich die Veröffentlichung noch etwas hinziehen,
mit verkaufe ich nicht jetzt zu Sonntag passieren aber ich kann nicht trotz deshalb schon mal empfehlen jetzt schon mal den Kohlenpott zu abonnieren den ich tatsächlich für einen sehr interessanten,
Podcast Heike wie haben wir hier auch in der letzten Woche sagte ich hätte Kohlenbergbau endet und dann sagte Tim ja Gott sei Dank hier sind links linksgrün versiffter ökoteam.
Das hat da was da passt was da passiert ist jetzt und was die da gebaut haben das war schon wirklich eine sehr.
Krasse eine sehr krasse Erfahrung das zu sehen und was das für für die Menschen da bedeutet dass dieser dass dieser.
Teil der deutschen Geschichte jetzt irgendwie halt auch beendet wird das hat viele Facetten das hat gute Facetten das hat,
auch traurige Facetten und das hat vor allem eine sehr sehr viel,
Kultur und Schicksal was da irgendwie dran hängt und das finde ich äußerst interessant wie das im Kohlenpott immer wieder.
Auch von den verschiedenen Facetten beleuchtete destil Patos natürlich bei Kohlenbergbau im Ruhrpott das ist einfach eine ganz eigene
ganz eigene Kulturen ganz eigener stolz und auch eine ganz eigene Melancholie und auch eine
ja ne ne ne sehr also das ist im
immer noch ne echt nicht direkt Plackerei da unten die da eben auch auf eine Weise glorifiziert und auch
in meinen Augen bisschen schöner gemacht wird als das als Sie vielleicht dann doch jeden Tag ist aber das ist tatsächlich eine Kultur die,
die sich lohnt mal einzutauchen und die wahrzunehmen und sei es nur,
um den eigenen Erfahrungshorizont um dieses Stück Industrie Kultur,
inzwischen bei daneben Industriekultur Geschichte.
Zu erweitern insofern noch mal die Empfehlung für den Kohlenpott hier in eigener Sache und in ein zwei drei Wochen oder so,
wärmster noch nicht festgelegt wird dann eine etwas längere Folge dort zu hören sein die nicht ganz Metaebene Ton Qualitätsniveau hat weil man eben das Metaebene equipment,
nicht nach der unten schleppen durfte.
Ja und,
da fällt mir ein dass ich schon immer mal ein crevu Brote machen wollte und falls ihr wieder kompetente Gesprächspartner seid und mir einen Ritt in einem U-Boot auf mehr als 1200 m unter dem Meeresspiegel bringen kann damit ich diesen Trick Ortler Alpha bekannt.
Bitte nicht wieder zurück kommt ja ich bin für Hinweise dankbar.
Das hatte ich sowieso mal mehr CT mich an Anvers was was hältst Du davon ich bin ja ich bin ja da so ein bisschen eigen.
Und ich weiß aber dicke mal wieder ob das.
Duden eigen.
Tante so beim Kaffee,
eigenen sofern als dass ich nicht groß also ich,
kündige gerne Dinge nicht an bevor Sie fertig sind und das hatte ich gerade bei der Themensuche immer so eine Sache wir schreiben viele Leute auch und machen Themenvorschläge aber vieles
ich mache halt immer wieder ich kann eigentlich mal nur Sachen machen die mich jetzt auch selber rufen aber dann aktiv das Netzt und meine Kreise dafür zu benutzen um da groß
in der Öffentlichkeit Bus recherchieren habe ich dann immer deshalb nicht gemacht weil ich keine Erwartungshaltung sitzen wollte und dann wie diese Themen dann vielleicht doch nicht mache aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
öffne falscher Zurückhaltung.
Tim wenn immer du dir im Leben die Frage gestellt hast ob das falsche zurückkommt ist hast du noch die Antwort schon gekannt oder ist nicht der zurückhaltende.
Du kennst mich gar nicht.
Was kann ich was ich für ein schüchterner Scheurebe.
Also alles was dich in den in die in die Richtung bringt.
Wieder mehr CAE zu veröffentlichen solltest Du tun oder am verkürzt sich bei so einer Veranstaltung wo mich nachher auch jemand ansprach so hier.
Du machst doch auch mit mit Tim so ein Podcast ne und ich dachte ja gesagt totaler Fan von Tim.
Weil dieses BAE ich gesagt richtig eben aus das war hier ist jetzt geschehen.
Ach du alter du kleiner cupodcast also.
Fußball T-Shirt ich gut fand ich sehr schön.
Lutinus wenn wir die sind noch in guter Laune ja.
Bester Laune.
Euch auch.
Ich mach die nächsten paar Folgen nicht mit lass mich von Thomas und andre und vielleicht anderen offen dich gut vertreten und wir hören uns dann irgendwann wieder.
Bis dahin.